una partícula se mueve a lo largo del
eje x por lo que a cualquier tiempo t
mayor o igual a cero su velocidad está
dada por bp t igual a menos de al cubo
más 6 d al cuadrado más 2 t a qué valor
de t la partícula obtiene su aceleración
máxima
queremos saber cuándo es que obtiene su
aceleración máxima vamos a ver nos están
dando la velocidad en función del tiempo
y recordemos que si tenemos la posición
en función del tiempo supongamos que x
dt es una posición y está en función del
tiempo entonces si sacamos la derivada
de esto es decir x prima de t
esto será igual a la tasa de cambio de
la posición con respecto al tiempo oa la
velocidad en función del tiempo entonces
si sacamos la derivada de la velocidad
esa será la tasa de cambio de la
velocidad con respecto al tiempo y por
lo tanto es la
aceleración en función a el tiempo
entonces si nos dan la velocidad a
partir de eso podemos calcular la
aceleración vamos a reescribir eso
sabemos que vedette es igual a menos de
al cubo más 6 de al cuadrado más 2 t y a
partir de esto podemos conocer la
aceleración en función del tiempo pues
simplemente sacamos la derivada de la
velocidad con respecto a t entonces si
usamos la regla de la potencia nos queda
menos tres t al cuadrado más dos por
seis que es 12 entonces 12 t más 2 esta
es nuestra aceleración en función del
tiempo y queremos saber cuándo es que
logramos obtener la aceleración máxima
ok y sólo para verificar esta función de
la aceleración observen que es una
función cuadrática pues tiene un
polinomio de segundo grado y tenemos un
coeficiente negativo en el término más
alto
es decir el de segundo grado así que
esta es la función de una parábola que
se abre hacia abajo
miren tiene esta forma general sin duda
tiene un valor máximo pero como podemos
encontrar ese valor máximo bueno
ese valor máximo ocurrirá cuando la
pendiente de esta recta tangente sea
igual a 0 y también podemos verificar
que la parábola sea cóncava hacia abajo
en ese punto usando la prueba de la
segunda derivada es decir demostrando
que la segunda derivada sea negativa en
este punto entonces hagamos es
analicemos la primera y la segunda
derivada de la función de la aceleración
usaré otro color vamos a ver la primera
derivada es decir la tasa de cambio de
la aceleración es igual a menos 6 t más
12 ok y ahora pensemos cuando es que
esto es igual a cero bueno si restamos
12 en ambos lados
de la ecuación nos queda menos 6 t igual
a menos 12 y al dividir ambos lados
entre menos 6 nos queda te igualados así
que me pueden decir ok yo sé que esta es
una parábola que se abre hacia abajo
tengo un coeficiente negativo en el
término de segundo grado y sé que la
pendiente de la recta que pasa tangente
por este punto es cero cuando t es igual
a 2 por lo tanto éste será mi punto
máximo y podemos ir un poco más lejos
vamos a sacar la segunda derivada de la
aceleración la segunda derivada de la
función de la aceleración es igual a
menos 6 pues la derivada de menos 6 t es
igual a 6 y la derivada de una constante
es 0 entonces si la segunda derivada
siempre es negativa eso quiere decir que
siempre será una parábola siempre será
una parábola cóncava hacia abajo
entonces para la prueba de la segunda
derivada en dos la segunda derivada de
la aceleración es negativa por lo tanto
este es nuestro valor máximo el valor
máximo se encuentra en t igualados
entonces a qué valor de t la partícula
obtiene su aceleración máxima claro
cuando te es igual a 2